I'm going
[__]
hey wastelanders welcome back to the
vault of all things fall out
I'm overseer Dave here to welcome you to
your new home where modifications both
weird and wonderful live free now it's
hard to make friends in the Commonwealth
so make sure you treat any you may have
with kindness and consideration I know
he may be green Oakley violent and
probably smells bad
that doesn't mean strong doesn't deserve
a bit of protection and some sexy new
threads
this week's mod is Tumbo jammers power
armor for strong a brand new set of
power armor for everyone's favorite
jaded Jolly Green Giant the suit is
based on the xo1 power armor but shaped
and remodeled by tomba chamber it also
changes the appearance of strong giving
him a unique under armour and outfit as
a bonus the mod is completely compatible
with any xo1 paint job you've got
downloaded or any of the default armor
paints that already exists in the game
so you can keep your main man strong
looking so good you'll not even notice
the mutations
I've always liked mods that had a little
bit of character to your loyal
companions since it's their job to take
a few bullets for you it's only fair to
show strong the milk of human kindness
and keep them safe and sound
you can pick up this new suit by
visiting the advanced engineering
workbench and crafting it before handing
it over to the big green guy the armor
comes with all the lovely levels of
detail you'd expect from anything
already included the game the textures
and fresh model all look fantastic
as strong Wade's into the melee hammer
in hand this armor fits the world and
law of fallout perfectly it's as if
strong used as superhuman strength to
peel the armor plates off an old suit
and hammer them into place to fit his
larger frame if you're wandering around
the wasteland with the main man strong
make sure you visit the modern Nexus to
get this module self then come back and
let us know what you think of his new
attire I've been Dave the super mutant
tailor you can find me on twitter at
regular dave and until next week where
we'll have another episode and another
mod stay safe out there wasteland ax